okay Cheryl important question have your
kids ever mistaken a certain feminine
product for something completely
different no but I do know where you're
going with this Serena Williams knows a
thing or two about you know all of it
because she shares a hilarious Tick Tock
of her five-year-old daughter Olympia
mistaking a tampon for take a look
[Music]
what is that huh what's that a cat toy
for karma it's a cat toy for our cat or
Karma
but our cat name is karma right yes
yes it is
[Music]
you got some more tattoos no because the
one with the feet
let's see
this is okay
whatever was it oh I don't remember okay
let's not no let's not play with too
many of those no
these ones
I'm just using one more I'm just using
this one and I'm done
I mean they yeah a cat would find that
highly entertaining she's not wrong I
feel like she's right you know but I
love kids perception of things it's
amazing it's so pure it's like it's cat
toy exactly I think my daughter was I
don't know three or four and I didn't
have tissue I had a tampon in my bag and
she had a nosebleed so I stuck up the
tampon up her nose I mean that was
brilliant you've got to do what you got
to do and she walked around with them
there you go tap on over nose it was
great sorry kid and if it worked it
worked it works